-Guys, it's time for
"Tonight show Hashtags."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Hey, we do this thing
every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week I thought it would be
fun to try
"Add a Word, Ruin a TV Show."
For example, I sent out
a tweet that said,
"The Last Chicken Dance."
That's my go-to, man.
[ Laughter ]
They don't do that
at weddings anymore.
-Oh, the chicken dance.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, sure, they do.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Nah.
-I don't get invited
to weddings anymore,
so maybe they do.
Do you think they do?
-I know they do.
-No.
No, they do the other one,
like...
move to the left --
-Oh, yeah,
the cha cha slide?
-Yeah, they do that
instead of the chicken dance.
-No, they do it in addition.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
Freeze it.
Within minutes, it became
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you
for playing along.
We love playing this with the
Twitter and all that stuff.
So thank you, guys,
so much for doing this.
It's fun.
We do it every week.
So now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Add a Word, Ruin a TV Show"
responses from you guys.
This first one's from
@amandathinks13.
She says,
"Love Handles Island."
Ah.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a realistic
dating show.
This one's from
@ilovegiraffes.
She says,
"Daniel Tiger King."
Ah.
That's unfortunate.
This one's from @lime-a.
She says, "Crop Top Chef."
If you can't handle the heat,
put on a crop top.
This one's from @MissCoachK.
She says, "The Baby-Sitter's
Fight Club."
Oh, yeah.
First rule of Fight Club,
no jumping on the bed.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from
@RebeccaKilcline.
She says
"Mitsubishi Outlander."
Is that a real thing?
Could be. Could be.
Sounds like a Mitsubishi car.
-Yeah, there's a car that they
make called the Outlander.
-It's a Subaru.
-Oh, there is?
-Yeah, Subaru.
-Wait, Subaru Outlander?
-Subaru Outlander, ain't it?
-I mean, I -- you would know.
-No, Kirk would know.
-No, you're a soccer dad.
-No, Kirk has a Subaru.
-Hey, guys, guys, guys,
let's take it to --
let's settle this at
"The People's Court."
-All right, all right, okay.
-Let's call Judge Judy
on this one, man.
Mitsubishi Out -- Subaru
Outlander sounds about right.
-Yeah.
-But Mitsubishi should think
about maybe owning it.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Outlander.
This one is from @LaichItIs.
He says, "Whose Cocaine Line
Is It Anyway?"
[ Laughter ]
That show's only -- that show's
only ten minutes long.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this last one here's
from @jroddcasell.
He says, "Picard Anycard."
[ Laughter ]
Ah. There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.
It's interesting saying
this without --
Usually I'm yelling it
over the band.
-I know.
-So I don't even know
what I'm saying.
-Just yell it anyway.
-Okay.
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.